chuckle you've talked about how getting
in there into adversarial relationships
is pointless but people always get into
adversarial relationships with me I've
been told I'm scary before but never
understood why my question is how do I
maneuver on this without acting like a
little weakling bitch to appear less
threatening do I just accept that I rub
people the wrong way so this is a
question I'll do my best to answer
because it's time for definitely time
for some self-awareness here for the
individual asking this question it
sounds like you are you know a big
abrasive person that is aggressive and
intimidates people and I know what it's
like to be that person because I could
be I could come across as intimidating I
know that I can definitely come across
as aggressive I can be aggressive I am
aggressive in many ways abrasive I don't
know that not necessarily categorizes me
because I'm very cautious about not
being abrasive because if I'm being
abrasive with people am i building a
relationship under make any progress the
answers obviously no so something the
thing is when I hear this type of
question I I think that there's some
little bit of insecurity going on here
right some little bit of a that's not an
insult that's what I sense because
everyone's got insecurities I do
everybody does and but but the fact that
you ask this question I'm hoping that
that means you want to make some kind of
improve right you want to get better and
you know I'm a little worried that you
might just be looking for like
reinforcements because people think
Jacques was big and aggressive so if I
say I'm big and aggressive you know John
who's just gonna say hey those people
are just scared of you and they don't
deserve your mercy or you don't you
you use your intimidation factor to
overrun those people right that might be
what you're looking for but you
gonna get that here and the reason
you're not gonna get that here is cuz
that's not gonna help you it's not gonna
help you achieve your goals and you talk
about people being scared of you but the
fact likely is is that you're the one
that's scared and you actually said it
yourself that you don't want to appear
to be weak mmm you don't want to appear
to be a bitch
little right that is that feeling that's
fear
that's fear it's fear of looking weak
it's fear of looking wrong it's fear of
failure and it's fear of vulnerability
and those are those are real those are
real and if you're you know everybody
should be feeling those fears at some
level but you have to overcome those
fears if you don't then how are you ever
gonna step up if you're if you're too
afraid to be wrong how are you ever
gonna answer a question if you're too
afraid to look weak how ever you ever
gonna exposures any weaknesses if you
don't expose any weaknesses well just
build a bunk around yourself and sit in
there by yourself so as a leader we know
that up and down the chain of command
you need to develop relationships right
that's what that's what you're supposed
to do that means you need to communicate
with people that means you need to talk
and you need to listen and you need to
develop trust and one of the best ways
to develop trust with other people is by
exposing some vulnerability by saying
hang on not quite sure how to do this or
heck oh hey can you can you help me with
this issue I have going on here I don't
know how to solve it
that's ways that you build trust and
thereby build relationships and it's
hard to do that because you don't want
to look stupid you don't want to look
weak you don't want to admit you don't
know something because you want to be
mr. strong and know
everything in so you're probably putting
up a front
an aggressive front an abrasive front
it's a wall to keep people intimidated
and then in your mind you think it's not
my fault it's their fault cuz they're
scared of me it's their fault because
I'm so intimidating so that is not good
and then you get the your kind of
closing statement should you just accept
that I rub people the wrong way you can
you can accept that you rub people the
wrong way but then you might as well
accept right then and there that you're
never gonna be a true leader that you're
never gonna build any relationships that
you're never gonna inspire anybody and
you're never gonna be the leader of a
badass unified high-performing team
probably not worth it and the the better
thing to do is to humble yourself is to
open yourself up to the pain and the
discomfort of displaying weakness and
error and failure and open yourself up
to try and be nice to other people
instead of being scared and what's gonna
happen if you expose yourself go ahead
and throw it out there act pleasant to
them so they talk to you without fear
and in doing those things you can
overcome whatever these on insecurities
are and I don't know what insecure do
you have it could be any number of
things maybe you don't think you're
smart as they are maybe you don't think
you're as well educated as they are
maybe you don't think that they have you
have the strategic vision that they have
whatever those insecurities are it's all
good we all got no big deal but if you
stop hiding them and you own them you
will become not only a better leader
but you become a better man so take a
breath and get home and take another
crack at this gig hmm you know I think
losing your temper is a huge red flag
like I've always said and always will
say usually if you ever lose your temper
and I'm nothing screaming yell I'm just
saying you're getting mad at displaying
that anger well what's really what's
really what's really bad is when people
utilize their temper as a tool to scare
and intimidate people yes the gone man I
don't want to say anything to jock on
this cuz he's gonna kaluza's lose his
temper lose mind go crazy mm-hmm like
that that's that's me using it as a tool
which is not good because you're not
building any relationships you're not
getting any input from people you're not
respected by the way people might fear
you if you have a bad temper but they
don't respect you they're not calling
you up and asking you for advice they're
not wanting you to run their their
project ya know and they're not
motivated to do good by you when you're
not around they are definitely not
motivated to do good by you and you're
not around in fact the only reason they
do anything is out of fear you know
whereas if you have a relationship with
them you could leave for six months and
the people that know you and respect you
and care about you and everything
they're still busting their ass to do
the best they can for you
yep glad when you come back - yeah yeah
in a lot of times like so the
adversarial relationship thing but
there's a way to look at it is it kind
of takes both you to kind of cultivate
an adversarial relationship goes for any
kind really no yes and no okay so here
you you keep being a dick to me we'll
say and if I just keep being nice to you
even though you're being a dick to me
even though we have a job to do with it
yes all that and we're maintaining the
integrity of that but I'm keep being
nice to you you keep being a dick to me
I keep being nice to you
after a while the way that shakes itself
out is I'd be nice you know expert on
the denominator
ya know well here's the thing we're
still getting the job done or whatever
but my Rhys my response to you if you be
a dick to me is not be a dick back or
defend you know it's it's just be nice
oh you know so where are you gonna say
it shakes out as it shakes out the one
guy who's a dick stands out so
everyone's being cool and when all is
said and done we're just dealing with
one guy is a dick so if you if if you
cultivate the adversarial relationship
it's like okay you have this competitive
situation no trifle you know or dick you
guys that are jerks yeah what you end up
with yeah and let's say you were a nice
guy to begin with don't become a a jerk
now you know mm-hmm it's true so and I'm
say that because a lot of times when if
you're like a people are create a
creating adversarial relationships with
me you're gonna play a part in that
relationship you know yeah yeah and the
thing with this question and you know I
mean even the terminology used which
which is you know how do I maneuver on
this without acting like a little bitch
yeah literally so you gotta figure not
not you know not the most mature person
so I'm guessing hey man you're probably
22 you know 24 something like that or
you're haven't matured a lot in you're
27 but you're still caught in that in
that game and I think a lot of times you
know people when they when they meet me
or they they learn about me or I show up
at their business they think I'm gonna
be that guy that's like we're gonna just
come in here and and it's it's always
really cool when people go man yeah I
didn't think of that it's oh you have
this approach that we didn't expect and
I'm like yeah you know and by now most
people kind of you know at this stage
and national on front and when I show up
somewhere people have listened apart as
they know where I'm coming from
yeah now but you know two years ago you
know they expected this big sergeant
slaughter type thing to go down these
folks and yeah I'm gonna whip these
people into shape and
my guess is that the individual that
asked this question was kind of thinking
he would get some moral support from me
and I'm trying to give him moral support
because I wanted to be successful
because I want him to go out and
dominate in the world but to go out and
dominate in the world you have to be a
chess player not a checkers player you
gotta you gotta think you gotta use the
relationships you got to use indirect
warfare to go out there and be blunt
force trauma and everybody it'll get you
it'll get you you know it'll get you
with a quarter of the way there mmm if
you're lucky and then it won't get you
the rest of the way so just just it's no
big deal man you're you young you've got
some learning to do that's awesome I
wish I would have been smart enough to
ask this question when I was a young
stupid 23 year old you got some you're
thinking you recognize that you're in a
situation so all you got to do is just
uh just start taking a different
approach a little bit more of an
indirect approach a little bit more of
an open mind a little bit more humility
don't worry about looking weak when you
the people that are scared to look weak
are the people that are weak the people
that are okay being exposed are the
people that are strong like I'm totally
comfortable with my leadership
capabilities so when I have an issue I'm
like hey I don't feel comfortable about
this I'm not worried that somebody's not
gonna say like oh well we don't think
you can handle this no no I actually I
know I can I've been in worse situation
so what do you got yeah so if you're
paranoid about looking weak it means you
probably are weak if you don't care
about being looking weak it probably
means that you're coming along you know
you're doing pretty good solid yeah
check so you don't need a hard shell if
you have a hard core but you need a hard
shell if you have a soft core yes that
is true kind of thing yes did you just
make that up yeah but I mean I'm not
looking at it like dang that was deep
I'm not I'm not thinking that but that
is a true statement if you're if you're
fundamentally sound on the internal and
the meaningful structure of your of your
being then you can withstand attack so
you don't need to put up a big wall
right right you know but if you're
fundamentally weak internally
and the fundamentals of your of your
being are weak then you need to put up a
big wall protection you need to go
around and bow up to people and yeah you
made aggressive weapons up there to
really keep them away you know some guns
some heavy